حول كل هذه التطورات معنا من تل ابيب
مراسلنا الياس كرام الياس نبدا بعك بال
الخبر الاخير الذي وصلنا بوصول 24 جنديا
اسرائيليا الى مستشفى سروك اثنين منهم
بحاله خطيره اضافه الى ما رشح حتى الساعه
عن هذا الحديث بين نتنياهو وبايدن عن
معركه خان
يونس بالفعل سلمى هذا ما تفيد به المتحدثه
باسم مستشفى سوروكا في بئر السبع وهو
المستشفى الاكبر في منطقه الجنوب الذي
ينقل اليه الجنود الاسرائيليون الجرحى من
المعارك في قطاع غزه على اعتبار انه ال
الاقرب وال المتحدثه بلسان المستشفى تشير
الى ان هنالك 24 جنديا اصيبوا في المعارك
نقلوا خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه الى
المستشفى اي جروح اثنين منهم وصفت بانها
بالغت الخطوره وتشير المتحدثه بان هنالك
على الاقل اكثر من 30 جنديا اسرائيليا ما
زالوا ايضا قيد العلاج في ال المستشفى
وهذا يدلل سلمى على حجم المعارك ال
الدائره في قطاع غزه ونحن كنا اليوم في
منطقه الغلاف وكنا نشاهد ايضا عمليات
الانقاذ المتتاليه التي تجري عبر وحده
الانقاذ الاسرائيليه التابعه للجيش
الاسرائيلي والمعروفه بوحده 669 واحده من
اربع وحدات ال المختاره في الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهي المقوله بانقاذ الجنود من
ميادين المعارك وهي كانت تنقل جنودا في
ساعات الصباح والمساء هذا في المنطقه
الشماليه كذلك هو الحال ايضا في المنطقه
الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه حيث ايضا تجدد القتال
هناك فيما يخص سلمى الاتصال الهاتفي مع
الرئيس بايدن بين الرئيس بايدن ورئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو لم يرشح الكثير
ديوان رئاسه الوزراء الاسرائيليه لم يشر
حقيقه الى فحوى هذا اللقاء سوى انه تحدث
بالعموميات عن انه تناول مساله الحرب في
قطاع غزه لكن واضح بان اهميه هذا الاتصال
تاتي بعد اقل من 24 ساعه على تصديق المجلس
الوزاري المصغر للشؤون السياسيه والامنيه
في اسرائيل على طلب امريكي بزياده كميات
الوقود الداخله الى قطاع غزه كما هو معروف
يدخل يوميا 60,000 لتر من الوقود المجلس
الوز الاري المصغر صدق على ادخال 120,000
لتر من الوقود لكن الطلب الامريكي كان
ادخال
18000 لتر لكن اسرائيل ارادت ان تفعل ذلك
بشكل تدريجي وفي محاوله ربما في المقابل
ان تطلب ادخال الصليب الاحمر الدولي
لزياره المحتجزين الاسرائيلين في داخل
قطاع غزه مقابل رفع هذه الكميات الى ما
تطلبه الاداره الامريكيه وهو كسقف كحد
اقصى 180 ين الفلتر لكن واضح بان هذه
المكالمه مهمه لان الاداره الامريكيه تريد
ان تضع ضوابط ل اسرائيل في استمرار
عمليتها العسكريه في الجنوب ومنها مساله
ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه والطبيه بما في
ذلك الوقود الى داخل قطاع غزه تريد ان
تتاكد من خلال هذه الضوابط بان اسرائيل
تحترم القانون الدولي وقانون الحرب واللا
تسعى الى اقتلاع الفلسطينيين كما فعلت في
المناطق الشماليه من دياره لكن بطبيعه
الحال واضح بان اسرائيل حتى هذه الضوابط
لا تنفذها لكن الاهم ربما في هذه المكالمه
ايضا سلمى هو ما تريد الاداره الامريكيه
استطلاعه حول مواقف اسرائيل مما بعد الحرب
ما الذي ما هي الرؤيه السياسيه التي توافق
عليها اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بمصير قطاع غزه
بعد انتهاء المعارك العسكريه وبعد تحقيق
هذا في هذه الحرب وهو القضاء على حركه
حماس لان الاداره الامريكيه
متماهية تدعمه لكن الاداره الامريكيه في
المحصله العامه وكما قالت نائبه الرئيس
كاميلا هارس وهي حددت هذه المعايير
الاداره الامريكيه لا تريد احتلال قطاع
غزه من جانب اسرائيل لا تريد اقتطاع اراضي
من قطاع غزه ولا تريد ان يستمر الحصار ولا
تريد ان يقتلع الناس وتريد اعاده السلطه
الفلسطينيه الى اداره شؤون قطاع غزه على
اعتبار ان القطاع والضفه الغربيه المحتله
هي اراضي فلسطينيه واذا ما نظرنا الى هذه
النقاط الخمس اسرائيل تعارضها جمله
وتفصيلا لان اسرائيل تقول بانها هي من يجب
ان تبقى مسؤوله امنيا على قطاع غزه وهي
تتحدث ايضا عن اقتطاع اراض من من قطاع غزه
من اجل تشكيل هذا الحزام الامني الذي
تتحدث عنه والذي يفترض ان يشكل عمقا امنيا
يحمي غلاف غزه والبلدات الاسرائيليه
بالنسبه لاقتلاع الناس نحن راينا انها
هجرت نحو 100 مليون فلسطيني من المناطق
الشماليه وهي تهجر الاف الفلسطينيين يوميا
في المناطق الشرقيه الان لخان يونس وربما
هذا ينسحب ايضا على مناطق اخرى
في المنطقه الجنوبيه لل القطاع لذلك هنك
هنالك خلاف كبير بين الاداره الامريكيه
واسرائيل حول الرؤيه لمستقبل قطاع غزه
اسرائيل تقول لا لا لا والاداره الامريكيه
ربما تطلب من اسرائيل تقولوا لنا ما ما هو
نعم فبالتالي هنالك خلافات كبيره فيما
يتعلق بهذا الموضوع اسرائيل لا تريد عوده
السلطه الفلسطينيه وتقول بانها لا تريد اي
سلطه ت ددخل الى القطاع ل ل تدعم الارهاب
او تمول الارهاب او تثقف على ثقافه
الارهاب و عدم الاعتراف باسرائيل سلام